The football World Cup will take place in Russia...
...for the first time next summer from June 14th until July 15th.
Germany will defend its title after winning the 2014 World Cup in Brazil.
12 stadiums and 11 towns situated across three time zones...
...will host the 32 qualifying teams for the 21st World Cup.
Both the opening match and final will take place in Moscow...
...in the iconic Luzhniki Stadium,...
...formerly known as the Central Lenin Stadium,...
...which can host more than 80,000 spectators.
With an average distance of 600 kilometers between host cities...
...and 3,000 kilometers separating the most eastern location from the most western,...
...travel logistics for supporters and sportsmen...
...is one of the most demanding aspects of the competition,...
...but it's security which poses the biggest challenge...
...for the world's largest sport event.
Russia faces the twin threats of terrorism and hooliganism.